bienvenidos a enlace centroamericano
este capítulo desde san juan del obispo
una aldea a 1600 metros sobre el nivel
del mar al occidente de guatemala y bajo
las faldas de el imponente volcán de
agua
hoy abordaremos como el cambio climático
ha influido en la vida de miles de
campesinos y trabajadores de
centroamérica un fenómeno una emergencia
climática que los ha perjudicado al
punto de hacerles perder la cosecha de
todo un año de trabajo o incluso al
extremo de hacerles vender sus tierras
para emigrar hacia eeuu
pedro chacón cican es un agricultor con
más de 450 árboles de níspero que vive
en uno de los ocho estados de guatemala
donde el presidente alejandro giammatei
decretó el estado de calamidad pública a
finales de junio él es uno de los dos
millones de pequeños productores de
centroamérica que subsiste gracias a la
economía de sus cultivos consideró que
hace 20 años para atrás en los inviernos
eran normales comenzaba en mayo llovía
lo normal tenía la canícula 8 15 días y
seguía igual hasta octubre pero ahora a
veces llueve bastante una semana y tres
no llueve
o hay
años aunque hasta dos meses dentro del
de los meses de invierno no caerá lluvia
y eso
crea desbalance en los árboles en los
alrededores de antigua guatemala los
agricultores suelen cultivar este tipo
de árboles el de níspero o el de café
que dan unos frutos muy agradecidos
cuando vienen las épocas de lluvias pero
quienes en el resto del territorio
guatemalteco cultivan por ejemplo maíz y
frijol son quienes realmente sufren las
inclemencias del clima de la ola
invernal porque sus productos se echan a
perder cuando hay mucha lluvia
hay vientos fuertes
si se cultivan maíz se cae y ya no se
recupera claro solo que tengan grandes
tierras pero aún contigo tecnificado de
lo contrario con el azadón no van a
salir entonces tienen que buscar otros
horizontes y es ahí donde se da la
migración
nos encontramos ahora en ciudad de
guatemala una de las siete capitales de
centroamérica este territorio es el
punto caliente más prominente de los
trópicos y emerge como la zona más
vulnerable del mundo al cambio climático
de acuerdo con el centro de pensamiento
de costa rica- estado de la nación en
guatemala los investigadores de la
universidad del valle analizan como el
aumento de un grados celsius en la
temperatura de la región ha alterado la
exactitud de las épocas de lluvia un
ejemplo es lo ocurrido entre 2015 y 2020
cinco años en que la temporada invernal
se retrasó un par de meses del
calendario habitual y los cultivos de
miles de agricultores se secaron por
completo estas personas usualmente
pequeños agricultores estamos hablando
de pequeños porque los grandes si tienen
sistema de riego y ellos no dependen
tanto de la lluvia usualmente gente que
ya vive en pobreza hay gente que vive
con muchos problemas socioeconómicos y
un evento como esto de una pérdida de
cosecha puede ser lo que cause que
finalmente decidan tomar una acción tan
drástica como
relacionar migración y cambio climático
aún es una hipótesis pero según los
investigadores de la universidad del
valle de guatemala lo que sí es evidente
en su observación científica es que las
lluvias del siglo 21 son más intensas y
las sequías más prolongadas que las
registradas en el siglo 20
el clima de centroamérica es muy
variable y además tenemos muy pocos
datos históricos por lo tanto todavía no
podemos decir de que las variaciones de
lluvia que estamos observando en las
últimas dos décadas sean debidas al
cambio climático en otras palabras es
posible que todavía tengamos que
llamarlo como variabilidad natural del
clima porque todavía no tenemos
suficiente información para ver las
tendencias de largo plazo el instituto
nacional de meteorología de guatemala
insivumeh pronosticó para el 2022 un
promedio de 16 a 22 tormentas tropicales
además se prevén fuertes huracanes que
azotarán tanto el atlántico como el
pacífico de centroamérica y que suelen
cobrar la vida de decenas de personas y
dejar damnificadas a millones de ellas
por derrumbes las inundaciones la
inseguridad alimentaria y los daños a la
infraestructura
uno de los indicadores más claros de si
hay afectación por el cambio climático
de nuestra región son ciertas
modificaciones en el comportamiento de
la lluvia se va a modificar
temporalmente va a haber
más lluvia en menos tiempo y también va
a haber una modificación espacial va a
llover en lugares donde anteriormente no
es que no hayan llovido pero su
comportamiento podría incrementar a
nivel anual
tres de los países de centroamérica han
estado recientemente en la lista de los
10 más vulnerables del mundo de acuerdo
con el índice global de riesgo de cambio
climático honduras nicaragua y guatemala
paradójicamente tres países con una
bajísima emisión de gases de efecto
invernadero el presidente de guatemala
alejandro giammattei le pidió a la onu
que declaré a centroamérica como una
región de mayor vulnerabilidad climática
para captar recursos de los países
industrializados así terminamos este
capítulo en la cámara estuvo mi colega
aurora value y ustedes recuerden que
este enlace centroamérica lo pueden
consultar en nuestro sitio web france24
puntocom hasta la próxima